so therefore how do these work I'm gonna
use the third column over here make a
little subheading you can call it how do
these work okay so what you're looking
at here is an example of the pair of
equations that are with what we call as
the name suggests parametric equations T
is the parameter so we call this pair
equations the parametric equations
because they include a parameter in them
I'm defining X&Y in terms of that T
value okay now what I can do is I can
take these guys and I can convert them
into a Cartesian equation like for
example the Cartesian equation of this
guy of the unit circle is what is the
Cartesian equation it's just x squared
plus y squared equal one very good
morning so this is a Cartesian equation
I wonder if you can think by the way of
how we get that from these guys I'll
come back to that in a minute how would
I get rid of because you see this
doesn't have any parameter in it anymore
what I want to try to do is eliminate T
I want to eliminate the parameter right
so to eliminate the parameter the stock
standard way of eliminating a variable
if you're solving some simultaneously is
to do it by substitution right like if I
gave you something like this X minus y
equals five 3x plus 4y equals eight for
instance I could take this equation I
could add Y to both sides if I add a way
to both sides I'd get this do you see I
can use that guy substitute him into
here and eliminate out all the XS does
that make sense
I'll get a new equation here it'll look
like this and lo and behold I have
eliminated that variable I want to do
the same thing over here except the
particular variable I want to get rid of
is the parameter so which equation would
you like me to go after here's one he is
sue which do you think might make it
easier for me yeah okay if I go with the
first equation with X in it what would
you like me to do to both sides I'm
gonna rearrange one in what particular
way / - a will work so if I divide both
sides by two a here I get this like so
so be that I got this from equation one
I'm gonna call this one a and what would
you like me to do with that yeah just
like I was showing with the regular
simultaneous equations I'm going to
substitute this guy into equation two
sub that into that all right let's see
what emerges so Y is going to be equal
to a times X onto a or squared X on to a
or squared is that okay it's just a
straight substitution I can simplify
this a little bit this is a outside of x
squared on what good because you're
squaring both the two and the a so that
looks good so far I can see some kids oh
it's gonna happen kids or kids or at
least we've just on the denominator for
a so what seems like a natural thing to
do here
I think I'll multiply through and get
rid of all the fractions in that kind of
thing so you should recognize this right
what's this what is this guy this is
this is the parabola and in fact this a
is not just anything the reason why this
a is in here is because a is the what of
this parabola think about yeah it's the
focal lengths right so this here is now
no longer a parametric equation because
there's no parameter anymore so this guy
is the Cartesian equation
okay